quand on a préparé cette émission il m'a
dit diriger envie tu me fasses des
surprises mais j'ai envie mais aussi de
faire des surprises et il sait qu'il a
de nombreux fans de nombreuses fans et
kenji il ya une petite fille qui
s'appellent norah on l'a vu il ya de
quelques instants on est en train de
dîner avec sa famille elle pense qu'elle
va venir assister à l'émission n'oubliez
pas les paroles c'est bien aussi
il ya aussi regarder ses parents nous
ont laissé un petit message bonjour baba
depuis trois ans le ciel nous est tombé
sur la tête
les médecins nous ont annoncé que nora
avait une leucémie ce jour là tout a
basculé pour nous nous sommes tombés
dans un combat de longue haleine
non elle est pleine de vie elle aime
danser jouer chanter elle joue du piano
et surtout super fan de kenji
aujourd'hui après un dur et le combat
n'aura est enfin une émission et c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui il faut bien lui
faire une énorme surprise en la faisant
rencontrer kenji si jamais tu peux nous
aider à lui redonner le goût de vivre et
continuer son combat ce serait super
merci alors
nora elle était en train de dîner au
restaurant à côté sa maman lui a dit tu
vas assister à l'émission n'oubliez pas
les paroles l'enregistrement est c'est
pas du tout cas kenji si elle ne sait
pas qui à valérie benaïm elle préfère
qu'elle ne sait rien du tout elle a une
chanson préférée c'est yahoo
elle va venir sur le plateau on lui a
bandé les yeux elle n'entend rien elle
ne vois rien là elle va arriver sur un
plateau on ne sait pas où elle arrive et
elle va découvrir
kenji et le plateau de touche pas à mon
kenji et qu'elle jce tu peux prendre ta
guitare et lui sert carrément tiago je
pense que ça va être plus beau cadeau de
sa vie alors je pense qu'elle va elle va
halluciné ont valu signer alors
alors là elle en train d'écouter m
pokora ce qu'on ne ferait pas revenir
sur une prochaine n'aura nord-est que tu
m'entends oui est ce que tu sais où tu
es non je sais pas du tout c'est pas du
tout tu es ce que est ce que ma voix te
dit quelque chose
si ray lane n'a pas mal non
si tu es sur le plateau de touche pas à
mon poste on est en direct
mais la surprise en fait c'est pas moi
parce que la surprise
[Applaudissements]
laquelle
l'acquis quoi tu crois pas du tout la
non la tête là tu te dis là c'est c'est
un rêve
oui c'est un truc de fou bon bah oui
alors je sais que c'est l'été tu sa
première fois que tu le vois août aussi
près oui je l'avais déjà vu en concert
mais pas d'aussi près je sais que tu as
une chanson que tu adores c'est tiago
allez allez allez
elle est folle de calvi et il est bon
nous as qu'il est beau c'est moi aussi
c'est pas mon délire mais c'est pas ça
tu trouves tu aimes bien c'est quoi ta
chanson préférée c'est tiago en ce
moment je sais comme monfils n'écoute
que ça est ce que tu veux qu'ils la
fassent que pour toi ce soir
oui tu veux lui demander où tu veux que
je demande moi j'aime bien savoir le
public vous allez on y va ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jaloux
puis
le temps de décrire
[Applaudissements]
alors
ok
dans l'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
ils sont d'accord
m
non
tél
[Applaudissements]
hazan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
absolument faire ce cadeau parce que
cette vidéo est là elle m'a beaucoup
touché merci à vous en tout cas eh ben
c'est pas moi c'est à kenji qu'il faut
dire merci et surtout qui a été
formidable une faute plus parce que tous
les cas un gros câlin mais un devoir
pour toulouse j'ai vu que tout agent au
corps à la prochaine fois je vais venir
pour m pokora aussi c'était un truc tu
préfères je le sais je te fais un énorme
bisou merci